Speaker 1: Twitter is undeniably collapsing
at this point in time.
The defenders of Elon Musk's takeover insist
everything is fine.
Any user of Twitter, if you're paying attention,
you can tell something is not right on the
platform.
We now have a new report.
Twitter hit by a staggering 59% drop in U.S.
ad sales.
Twitter's U.S. ad revenue has plunged dramatically
in the wake of Elon Musk's takeover of the
site, according to The New York Times.
The newspaper reports an internal Twitter
presentation showed the company's American
ad sales in the five weeks from April one
into early May were at $88 million, a whopping
59% lower than the same period a year earlier.
Unnamed current and former employees say Twitter's
ad sales staff are worried that advertisers
may have throttled spending out of concern
about an increase in hate speech and porn
on the platform, along with a surge in advertisements
for cannabis products and online gambling.
Six ad agency executives say clients continue
to limit Twitter spending out of confusion
about Musk's changes to the site, as well
as inconsistent support from Twitter.
Meanwhile, Twitter's head of brand safety
and ad Quality will be leaving.
This was announced three days ago.
This is A.J.
Brown, Twitter head of brand safety and ad
Quality, has decided to leave.
Additionally, we found that twitter's head
of trust and safety has resigned.
This is L.A. Irwin told reuters thursday.
She's out.
She has faced criticism for lax protections
against harmful content since musk acquired
the platform.
Apparently unable to do anything about it,
she has also resigned.
So listen, i am actually, i don't find this
to be a great thing.
You know, i've been on twitter for a long
time and spent time building a following and
have made some great contacts on Twitter and
Twitter.
As we know, it has essentially been destroyed.
The verified feed is now useless because anybody
can just pay eight bucks to get verified.
I used to.
I know people are like, Oh, David, that's
so elitist.
I would communicate with other verified people
on Twitter and the verification served to
say, this is really that person.
I don't now have to wonder, is this AOC or
is this the AOC parody account that Elon Musk
was signal boosting?
That was a bad move.
The new algorithmic for you feed.
I looked at it today.
It was posts from Michael Knowles, Matt Walsh,
and Brigitte Gabriel.
That's what for you was pitching to me.
People who don't pay the eight bucks are getting
deprioritized in the algorithm.
They're admitting this.
This isn't even me saying that.
Elon Musk said paying gets you prioritized
in the algorithm.
So I'm really not posting much.
And many people have written to me and said,
David, are you going to a different platform?
I'm on blue sky, but blue sky is really, really
small.
I don't know whether there's really going
to be a replacement to Twitter.
Something really in tangibly bad is happening
on Twitter and it only is logical to believe
that it is a result of Elon Musk's takeover
because all of this stuff happened since Elon
Musk took over.
Could it be a correlative thing and not causative?
I guess maybe, but it seems pretty clear what
is going on.
My hope is that it turns around because I
liked Twitter.
I still like Twitter as a platform.
But at this point it's, you know, every once
in a while I'll put something up there.
The engagements vary.
So so a ton of trolls, people I have to end
up muting and so on and so forth.
And even though Elon Musk claimed that ad
sales were off the charts, they're not.
They're not.
And Twitter truly is struggling there.
By one report, Twitter's value is down about
two thirds since Elon Musk purchased it.
We will follow it, but so far, not exactly
a heroic and inspiring tale.